cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com pacman the link is down
below
so it's been months since i did our last
sort of comprehensive covet update about
where we are and um sadly
the reason i'm doing such a segment
today is that many signs don't look good
and there's every indication that
another spike could be coming now
there's still
the possibility that that's not the case
and i'll talk about what that looks like
in a moment
but we will get to that um there is a
argument to be made that in general
cases are no longer really the best
indicator of the status of the pandemic
that we should be looking at
hospitalizations and deaths etc and i
think that there's something to that but
still cases are a leading indicator of
hospitalization and death the question
is just to what degree
now none of us want another spike
but unfortunately it does appear as
though one is coming and there is
evidence from other countries suggesting
this and unfortunately there's also
evidence from the united states and as
always i am always going to report to
you
the way things are
not the way i wish things would be so
first and foremost if we look at global
cases what has been a massive decline
from nearly 4 million cases a day
down well under 2 million cases a day
has reversed now this is global so the
we got down to a lower point
and global cases are now starting to go
up now they're not going up in the
united states yet although i will argue
that they actually are and we're
if you look at the right data that you
can see that
but where are we seeing actual recorded
case numbers increase well first and
foremost germany and they're not only
going up a little bit two days ago
germany had the most
new cases in a single day
of the entire pandemic it it's
exhausting i know it's exhausting
but about 300 000 cases in a single day
in germany
a pandemic record you look at finland
finland since about
mid-january has individually seen some
higher case days and if you look now at
the seven day rolling average of new
cases in finland
it is at a pandemic high
if you look at the united kingdom
massive decline remember at the peak of
omicron
the uk was seeing about 200 000 known
cases per day about 210 220. um that got
all the way down below 50k
and now has gone back up by by about
double i mean it's where the uk has
almost now doubled uh daily cases from
that um bottoming out we saw at the
beginning of march that's really not
good because so far in the pandemic
everything that's happened in the uk has
happened in the u.s a little bit later
um and then you look at iceland iceland
which i mean the entire pandemic looks
like almost nothing compared to the
current 2500 cases a day that iceland is
seeing essentially at a pandemic high
seven day average
and um lastly
if you look at uh oh i actually i
actually forget where this is it doesn't
say
i believe that this is
oh where is this this is somewhere in
asia i was trying to give a um
perspective globally i i did not even
include what country this is uh a new
high i think wow i don't remember where
that is we'll get that information
so
okay cases are going up elsewhere but
they're not going up in the u.s right
well not exactly uh in the united states
as i've told you before waste water
covered readings can be a leading
indicator even earlier than cases about
the direction that things are going
and although dr vincent racinello not
last time he was on with us said the
wastewater data is not an exact science
it is still a generally speaking leading
indicator and there's an article in
bloomberg
u.s sewer data warns of a new bump in
covid cases after lull data from
wastewater can spot a rise in infections
before it shows up in positive tests
and unfortunately it's not looking good
more than a third of the cdc's waste
water sample sites across the us
show rising covered trends from march 1
to march 10.
even though cases remain at a record low
the number of sites with rising signals
of covid is nearly twice what it was
during the february 1 to 10 period
it's not clear how many new infections
the signs in the sewage represent and if
they will turn into a new wave or will
it be just a brief bump on the way down
from the last one so obviously we all
hope
that this is going to be
maybe a leveling out in the united
states and then we continue down or
maybe a slight uptick
the unfortunate thing is if we're
totally honest and transparent if you
look at what's starting to happen in
other countries it doesn't bode
particularly well now
everything's wide open
even though you still have people
protesting mandates and closures in the
united states there essentially are none
everything's open everything's happening
and quite frankly i don't know what
should be taking place right now i i
there is such i mean it's been more than
two years now of this uh almost to the
day it's been two years and a week or
something like that of this at this
point in time the political will to
continue having things shut down is
almost completely gone
the social motivation to do it is almost
completely gone
the um infection fatality rate is
significantly lower that doesn't mean
that if things get completely out of
control in cases people aren't going to
die they are
um and
i am not in a position where i am going
to say
close everything um it uh we we now know
that close everything is too broad a
strategy
and we know that close everything in
many cases didn't even really achieve
what we wanted it to achieve
but
do nothing also doesn't make sense if we
see another spike so we're going to be
following the data
um we're going to be tracking what
happens particularly the uk numbers are
not looking good and so far we
everything that happens in the uk
happens here four to six weeks later
so my expectation is that by april 1st
we are going to see higher cases in the
u.s than we see right now why do i think
that because it's already in the the
wastewater data it's up it's already
there there's no way it would be any
other way the question is is it just a
little bump plateau and then we continue
down or not
and i don't know the answer to that
i want to talk a little bit today about
in cells now this is often mentioned
jokingly
but this is really a serious and
important thing it's often mentioned
casually you know a lot of terrorism a
lot of domestic terrorist acts at their
core
are the results of in cells now you
might not know what an incel is in cell
is short for involuntarily celibate
involuntarily
sell a bit in cell i hope that makes
sense and what it refers to
is an incel is someone who
would like to be in a sexual
relationship
but they are unable to get into one
because they either can't find someone
to be in such a relationship with or
they're too you know shy to try or
whatever so they're celibate but not
voluntarily involuntarily now whether
this is
funny or not
it's actually a real source of concern
about the radicalizing effect of in-cell
uh circumstances and there's a new
secret service report
exactly about this and i've mentioned
this in the past many times how many of
these incidents that we are seeing
are a combination of radical political
radicalization
and the frustrations of
involuntary celibacy of course of course
of course never saying
that anybody who can't find a date is
going to go out and commit violence or
act of terror overwhelmingly
almost none of the people that are
involuntarily celibate are going to go
out and commit acts of violence but is
it a factor among some of those that do
a very interesting cbs write-up
new secret service report details
growing in-cell terrorism threat the
federal government on tuesday today
released a study on the growing
terrorism threat from men who call
themselves anti-feminists or
involuntarily
celibates and draw motivation for
violence from their inability to develop
relationships with women tip almost
exclusively these are
heterosexual men who would like a
relationship with a woman and are unable
to find one since 2014 attacks inspired
by the incel movement and spanning the
u.s and canada have left dozens dead
early intervention and behavioral threat
assessments could be the difference
between life and death for women
targeted by the growing ideology
according to the 26 page report the
report concluded that while quote there
is no one profile of an individual who
plans or executes an act of targeted
violence investigators must consider
potential targets when seeking to thwart
attacks as suspects routinely quote
explore multiple targets during the
planning process before making their
final decision the u.s secret services
national threat assessment center took a
deep dive into a serious series of red
flags predating a shooting at a yoga
studio in florida to determine how early
intervention could have saved lives in
the case of 40 year old gunman scott
paul bayerly there were countless
warning signs the man who opened fire
inside hot yoga tallahassee killing two
women and injuring four before
committing suicide had previously been
fired from multiple teaching jobs barred
from bars and apartment buildings and
once authored a 70 000 word revenge
fantasy about a boy turned serial killer
um
there is a um
so put putting that particular um
story aside
uh the whole point here is an analysis
of the idea that there are people
motivated to carry out violence by their
inability to either develop or maintain
a relationship with women now the report
mentions and it's important to consider
the origins of anti-feminist
and in-cell movements vary and they're
not always the exact same thing so there
are people who are radicalized into
extreme anti-feminist ideology
um not necessarily by their personal
inability to to form a relationship with
a woman
um but some are
and then along those same lines
not all
incels are anti-feminists some are just
in cells and they're fine with feminism
but they just can't develop
relationships with women for what may be
a number of different
reasons now jordan peterson has actually
talked about this before jordan peterson
at one point talked about something
called enforced monogamy and he says
that's not literally like you force
people
you you don't forcibly pair women off
with men to prevent them from being in
cells but here's what jordan peterson
had to say about it okay so the question
is
what do you mean by enforced monogamy
well we could start by what i don't mean
i don't mean
taking innocent women at gunpoint and
handing them over to useless men that's
good okay that's a good thing
which is essentially the accusation
you know and it was really interesting
to watch that unfold what i meant was
that
monogamy
as a as something that's socially
uh valued is appears to be essentially a
human universal
that does not actually seem to be true i
mean it that that may well be true in
modern society but historically that's
that's not really been the case doesn't
mean that human beings are
universally monogamous because obviously
we're not we can be serially monogamous
and some people are players and have
multiple partners and all of that but
there's a strong proclivity
across
known societies
to tilt towards monogamy
and the enforcement is social norms
it's like think about it i can't believe
that i even have to say this
your son just gets married and he comes
home and he says guess what dad i've
been screwing around and what do you do
you pat him on the head and you say hey
good work kid that's that's my young man
right well no
you're not happy about that and he
doesn't tell you because he knows you're
not going to be happy about it and
that's enforced monogamy okay so the
idea here is basically the way to fight
this incel stuff is you have to
socially show
that monogamy is acceptable
and lack of monogamy is not but it
really doesn't actually solve the
problem even if if socially
not being monogamous is looked down upon
it's still not going to help a lot of
these in cells uh that that that's just
that's just the reality so it's not
clear what we do with this type of
information but it is clear that the
in-cell factor is a real enough factor
that the secret service threat
assessment is to take a term from the
former president looking at it very
strongly let me know your thoughts you
can find me on twitter at deepakman
one of our sponsors today is cheese
butter giving you 15
off i love this stuff cheese butter is a
delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry cheese
butter is giving my audience fifteen
percent off
when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman
so i wanna pick up our conversation
about uh tulsi gabbard that we started
yesterday but really this is now
becoming a much bigger story and one of
the things i'm going to show you in a
bit is the ukrainian bio labs people
that now are fixated on the ukrainian
bio lab story that's being promulgated
by you know tucker carlson glenn
greenwald tulsi gabbard the usual
suspects
these are folks who have sort of their
their shiny new object instead of covet
anti-vaxx has shifted to become
ukrainian bio labs it's the same people
they're just now paying attention to
something else so uh something really
funny has happened uh tulsi gabbard is
now suggesting that senator mitt romney
resign and the idea there is that
anybody cares
what tulsi gabbard thinks about who
should resign that that's that's
hilarious and all of this is centered
around tulsi gabbard repeating
known long-time russian propaganda
talking points about ukrainian biolabs
so just as a reminder here's the clip
that started it all here are the
undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according to the us government these bio
labs are conducting research on
dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities
even in the best of circumstances could
easily be compromised
and release these deadly pathogens
now like covid
these pathogens know no borders if they
are inadvertently or purposely breached
or compromised they will quickly spread
all throughout europe the united states
and the rest of the world causing
untold suffering and death
so in order to protect the american
people the people of europe the people
around the world
these labs need to be shut down
immediately and the pathogens that they
hold need to be destroyed
instead of trying to cover this up the
biden harris administration needs to
work with russia ukraine nato the u.n to
immediately implement a ceasefire for
all military action the vicinity of
these labs until they're secured and
these pathogens are destroyed now
understand that with all of these things
they have kernels of truth like for
example
are there laboratories in ukraine
yes there are laboratories in ukraine
that research pathogens and bio-weapon
defense they're not developing weapons
but they're researching pathogens and
bio weapons defense they there and and
also in many other european countries
and in other parts of the world so that
that's not untrue
um is it true that the us
through the dod is part of a consortium
that is supporting the research being
done in a variety of these labs around
the world yes that's true but there's
nothing pernicious about it
would that with the existence of such a
lab in ukraine in any way justify
russia's invasion no of course not are
these the us's labs to order shut down
no they're not and so where this gets
into propaganda territory is that
some of the
kernels that are there
aren't untrue in a literal sense but
it's being packaged as a way to provide
cover for talking about things other
than the completely outrageous russian
invasion of ukraine and specifically
this is why this russian
talking point has been a talking point
about ukrainian bio labs for so long now
mitt romney wasn't having it republican
senator mitt romney tweeted tulsi
gabbard is parroting false russian
propaganda her treasonous lies well may
cost lives well we've also since learned
uh that uh tulsi didn't like this and
tulsi started demanding that mitt romney
resign and the idea that anybody would
care what tulsi gabbard thinks at this
point is genuinely hilarious tulsi
doubled down on twitter and she said
maybe romney needs to resign tweeting
quote
mitt romney you have called me a
treasonous liar for stating the fact
that there are 25 us funded bio labs in
ukraine which if breached would release
and spread deadly pathogens to the u.s
and the world and therefore must be
secured in order to prevent new
pandemics now romney didn't say that
she's uh a traitor because she said that
that's what's going on um and it's not
clear that there are more than 25 in
ukraine that's actually a question marg
and they could spread if they were
breached but we don't know that to be
true but she went on to say you claim
that securing these labs is treasonous
no he didn't say that securing the lab's
easter egg labs is treasonous
she said the spread of pathogens is what
will cause the loss of life not the
prevention of such spread and then says
senator romney please provide evidence
that what i said is untrue and
treasonous if you cannot you should do
the honorable thing apologize and resign
from the senate now of course uh mitt
romney was saying that her parroting of
russian propaganda is what's treasonous
now do i think it's literally treason is
no it's it's almost certainly not and
mitt romney was using hyperbole but the
idea that tulsi is going to call for the
resignation of mitt romney is just
hilarious so the important things to
keep in mind about this story because
a week ago i would have said this is not
going to go anywhere
and now this story is everywhere and all
the usual suspects have seized on it the
substance of the story itself we went
over in detail yesterday in two segments
i don't want to do it all again since
you know how many times am i going to do
that in one week it's overall a really
great example of russell's teapot
russell's teapot is this idea
that bertrand russell came up with which
illustrates
the issue of burden of proof and in
particular burden of proof when people
make unfalsifiable claims rather than
shifting the burden of disproof to
others and the way bertrand russell
talked about it was in the context of
religion he wrote if someone says okay
there's a teapot
orbiting the sun
or you know orbiting somewhere uh
orbiting the sun somewhere between earth
and mars
and it's too small to be seen
you wouldn't expect that anybody would
believe that
just because they can't disprove that
there's this tiny teapot you can if he
says there's there's this tiny teapot
and it's too small to be seen and too
small to be detected
it's very hard to disprove that but that
doesn't mean we just assume that it's
true that there is such a teapot and
this entire thing is based on proof the
u.s is perniciously funding
biolabs bioweapons labs and there's
something dangerous going on or that
well we don't actually have proof of
that we we just have all we know is
there are labs all over the world
and they research pathogens and they
research how to defend against the bio
weapons attack no no no but it's
the the pernicious nature of these is
being covered up well so then how would
we know one way or the other well it's
up to you to prove that it's not going
on how do you prove something's not
going on we just don't have evidence
that it is going on it's similar to the
invisible tiger example i've used before
which is hey
in my studio right here there's an
invisible tiger
really but the i can't see it there no
but it's invisible okay well it's
invisible but it still has weight right
so if we put talcum powder down on the
floor
we should be able to see the tiger
disturb the talcum powder as it walks
around no because it's a weightless
invisible tiger oh okay all right well
but i'm sure then that if we uh um uh
open the door and put a little bit of
cellophane and then take the oxygen out
the tiger will try to leave the room and
we'll see it press up against the
cellophane right we'll see this no
because it's an invisible weightless
tiger that has the ability to go through
the cellophane
it's it's endless it's a bottomless pit
and uh we need to understand that not
only are these claims uh essentially
unfalsifiable to the people making them
these are also uh much the same people
who were doing the anti-vaxx they've
just found a a shiny new object here's
ben collins from nbc explaining this
let's talk about um
it reminds us of the theories that covet
19 was deliberately started in a lab and
spread out is does this start and live
in those kinds of places
yeah that account on gab was an
anti-vaxx account um you know that's the
the remaining legacy of the anti-vac
spaces on the internet they are
conforming to be part of the broader
global far right to push these
conspiracy theories against the bidens
against anthony poche and against what
they would call like the medical
establishment all throughout the world
the global far right has coalesced
around that and it's worked for russia
too and in fact you know the tas the
russian news agency um they didn't post
anything about biological weapons
attacks uh that were created in ukraine
in the run-up in the one month before uh
the invasion in ukraine but on thursday
and friday they posted 24 separate
articles about what they call biological
weapons in ukraine this so this is a
long time uh longtime story uh being
that that has come out of russia in the
past and now others are helping to push
it so that starts with tulsi gabbard
next we'll talk about madison cawthorne
so a radical republican trumpist
congressman madison cawthorne who knows
nothing about history nothing about
foreign policy nothing about geopolitics
nothing about economics nothing about
mathematics nothing okay you get it um
he has been taking the also very
friendly to russia approach of just
criticizing ukraine but criticizing
ukraine for things which really russia
can be more heavily criticized for
including a lack of democracy and so on
and so forth and this is just beyond
parody madison cawthorne did some kind
of a public event
and someone in the audience said
they wanted to know more about what's
really going on in russia and ukraine
and hilariously they want madison to
explain it to them which is just so
funny like why on earth would you go to
him but let's take a look at the clip
and see him trot out even more extreme
versions of the same talking points
anybody else
yeah
yes sir um
we got this mess in the
eastern europe there with ukraine and
all that i know you've made some
reference to uh
president zielinski being a thong or
being in the government being corrupt
we're all i think we're all trying to
figure this thing out i mean
it seems like we're on the precipice of
a
could be a possible major disaster can
you clarify some of that for us so we
know where we stand with that now before
we even hear the answer
dude this madison cothran doesn't know
anything this guy looks like he's you
know 55 60 65 i don't know um
how ignorant is he
that to find out what's going on with
geopolitics
he goes to an event with a a clueless
congressman
and asks him tell me what's really going
on okay i will so one as i was saying
earlier
there's so much propaganda coming out on
all sides of this boat from russia from
ukraine from a lot of other countries
involved from our own media
that things are becoming so murky and
hard to understand but so that's also a
really popular talking point they use
it's just so complicated that ufc guy
bryce mitchell also did it
we don't know what's going on it's crazy
before we all jump to a conclusion say
we're going to go defend a democracy in
eastern europe we have to realize that
there is
the ukrainian government is so well
known for corruption now remember the
russian government is more well known
for corruption and russia still invaded
ukraine
uh there's only it's one of the major
sex trafficking hubs of the entire world
russia is also a major sex traffic
trafficking hub of the world and it
doesn't justify the russian invasion of
ukraine
that area the ukrainian people are
wonderful people uh there's a lot of
really great people and those who are
patriarchy fighting for their freedom i
commend them they're doing great um
but this is not a country that you know
i i feel like is the shining beacon of
what really truly is the standard of a
good and clean and transparent
government and russia is even less a
standard of good and clean and
transparent government on any freedom
and democracy index ukraine ranks far
higher than russia but
either way
russia invaded ukraine so it's it's not
only is he
ignoring russia's record he's ignoring
that none of it would justify an
invasion anyway
and so there was a lot of corruption
that's been there you know 2014 there
was basically a regime change that
happened uh you know there's there's
just a lot of questions and questionable
issues going on there
i i do plan on releasing in detail in a
few weeks just kind of with some ideas
and some thoughts that i imagine waiting
around for madison cothorns report with
ideas okay so beyond parody here's a
bonus clip madison cawthorne in the
context of all of this strife
he mentions the bible
but he doesn't even know what he's
talking about when he mentions the bible
they would be easy to get
disheartened with the things going on
not only in our country but in our world
today uh their war is breaking out you
know in revelation we're talking about
there will be wars and rumors of wars i
think that's exactly what we're seeing
so not number one i don't know what the
hell the bible has to do with any of
this but his references are also
incorrect wars and rumors of wars is
from mark and from matthew i mean i
don't even care about this stuff but he
just happens to be wrong
in mark 13 5 jesus said to them watch
out that no one deceives you many will
come in my name claiming i am he and
will deceive many when you hear of wars
and rumors of wars do not be alarmed
matthew 24 4 jesus answered watch out
that no one deceives you
for many will come in my name claiming i
am the messiah and will deceive many you
will hear of wars and rumors of wars but
see to it that you are not alarmed do
they even care
that the bible stuff he's quoting isn't
accurate does anything matter at this
point
when people are going and asking madison
kawthorne for his view on geopolitics my
instinct is the facts don't matter we'll
have these clips on our instagram at
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
thomas homer dixon who's the executive
director of the cascade institute at
royal roads university in british
columbia canada his new book is
commanding hope the power we have to
renew a world in peril some of you may
may recognize his name because he was
also the author of an article we spoke
about in january called the american
polity is cracked and might collapse
canada must prepare it's really great to
have you on today i appreciate your time
delighted to be with you david so your
article was essentially written as a
cautionary
message to canada about you know us uh
the the traditionally democratic
neighbor to the south and the
possibility that by 2030 the u.s could
become uh to use your term a right-wing
dictatorship um can can we start by
talking about
uh
that that's only eight years a
relatively short amount of time
what would be the path for the u.s to
become that over the next eight years
in the article i
postulate that donald trump has
reelected in 2024
and that is really the critical stage in
the process that
could see the devolution of american
democracy into
an authoritarian regime of some kind
and people have been beating around in
the in the bushes about this using
various terms autocracy authoritarian
regime but i just say look
if we're going to have one person
putting himself above the rule of law in
the united states then then that is a
dictatorship and we should just call it
a dictatorship so the critical stage
would be donald trump's reelection
i don't know whether he would actually
consolidate
the a a right-wing dictatorship in the
united states it might take a period of
time it might be one of his successors
but i think
he would put
democracy in the united states in
extreme jeopardy i don't think there's
any doubt about that he would return to
office with the goals of vindication and
vengeance really and he would be
unleashed given that it would probably
be his last term in office
and uh i think that
creates enormous concern around the
world not just within the united states
yes so this was a warning to canadian
citizens to start preparing for this
possibility
the word dictatorship can mean in
practice many different things and
sometimes there's associations with uh
police states um uh you know just
willy-nilly imprisonment of media or
political dissidents uh people as you
know we sometimes say jokingly although
it's not a joke accidentally stabbing
themselves ten times when they happen to
you know this type of thing
which of these characteristics do you
think would be plausible in such an
american circumstance
that's a very good question i lay out a
number of pathways
in the article uh the most benign i
would be i would say something
resembling and this wouldn't really
qualify as a dictatorship of course
would something resembling victor
orban's
illiberal democracy in hungary yes but i
think we could go all the way through to
something closer to what we see in
russia right now under vladimir putin
that seems extreme and seems
implausible i think for many people
especially on the liberal end of the
spectrum but some of the rhetoric that
you're hearing now on the right
against media for instance
lock them up shoot them
even from people who are are
increasingly
accepted as part of the mainstream
discourse in the united states
it's rhetoric that you would expect from
uh of people who want to impose that
kind of
brutality within the american polity
so one of the points i make within the
article is that
uh
a a critical development here is the
propagation of what uh scholars call a
hardline security doctrine in the united
states
uh and it's been associated with some of
the most brutal regimes that transition
from democracy and i use the example of
weimar germany in the 1920s and 30s they
have a transition from democracy to a
dictatorship
and a critical element of that process
has been the propagation of a hardline
security doctrine which suggests for
people who adhere to it that there are
individuals within the society and
groups within the society embedded
across the society within civilian
sectors of the society that are
enemies of the state
who are and enemies of the nation more
generally and who have to be uh
identified and ostracized or even
eliminated and that kind of rhetoric is
now becoming much more common on the
right in the united states and that's a
precursor of of not just not just a soft
authoritarian regime but it's the kind
of thing you would see as a precursor
for a much more brutal regime
in the um in the aftermath of the 2020
election which donald trump who lost
claimed that he won
we were i mean
whether we were surprised is it is a
question but many of us were certainly
distraught that more than half of the
republican party believed it they they
at least said that they believed that
joe biden did not really win that
election can you talk a little bit about
in this potential dictatorial slide
how important does it matter whether a
significant portion of the population
buys the lies of the would-be dictator
oh it matters enormously it i mean it's
the one of the critical elements here
that is a poison and again it's quite
similar to
that that false falsehood
the big lie is quite similar to the
falsehood that
the nazis used to uh to
reinforce their own legitimacy the stab
in the back the the idea again listen to
the sort of the rhetoric of the hardline
security doctrine the idea that there
was a group in this particular
principally uh jews within within
germany who had conspired against
germany during the second world war
during the first world war at the end of
the first world war and it stabbed
germany in the back and it defeated
germany from within
and and uh
so the the lie that's being propagated
now the falsehood uh that um the
election was stolen from donald trump
enough
and widely believed and accepted
by supposedly somewhere around 70
percent of republicans now yeah
uh so what are we looking at 30 of the
american
electorate 25 to 30 percent of the
american electorate
uh it you you you can seize power within
a society
with a mobilized and coordinated
fraction of the society that large 20 to
30 percent absolutely 100
if everybody else is squabbling and
disorganized and not realizing what the
nature of the danger is
and not reinforcing the the the
institutions of democracy
it it's certainly large enough to
uh
impose a an institutional transition on
the society away from democracy
so yes that that
that falsehood and the fact that it's
widely believed and a substantial
proportion of of republicans also
believe that violence is justified in
returning
trump to the presidency or would be
justified
uh is as i say within the article
it's poison within the body politic of
the united states and it's coursing
through the entire body politic now you
mentioned um
world war ii and pre-world war ii era
germany
there's been i mean for decades at this
point you hear
some on the american right and maybe
elsewhere say
if the jews had had guns
the holocaust wouldn't have happened
historians have looked at this it's been
widely debunked and explained away
i
am curious about
what you imagine i mean gun culture in
the united states is very different than
in canada and i'm curious what you
imagine
the potential role of civilian owned
guns to be in an authoritarian takeover
of the us and this is with the specific
reality that
it's definitely
more of the folks
who believe the big lie that would be
likely to have the guns and this is why
among many of my liberal friends many
many are now saying
i'm not a big gun person but i don't
want them to be the only ones with the
guns
give us a sense whether you know you
have some thoughts as to the role of
civilian-owned guns in such a world
you know it's enormously important uh
so
in a sense and you're being very gentle
in your description of this situation by
the way
in in a sense what we have is the
development of an arms race and i and a
a weapons race between different
ideological camps in this highly
polarized society and then a
disintegration of what social scientists
call social capital which is the trust
the bonds of trust and reciprocity that
help bind societies together societies
with high social capital tend to prosper
solve their problems effectively and
those without don't and we're seeing
that
it's a it's a terrible degenerative
process and i think guns are
a really important element of that
because they induce a lot of fear
just as you were describing and the fear
causes the retreat to what what um
political scientists call a kind of
self-help situation where you feel you
have to take care of yourself and we all
feel that
and um now the irony is that the second
amendment and the gun culture in the
united states is ideologically justified
uh on the right by the fear of a tyrant
right that that we need to we need to
maintain our capacity to rebel against
an authoritarian state because that's
part of the
it's almost the civic religion of the
united states going back to the
revolution and and justifiably in in a
lot of ways of course the second
amendment is completely wildly
misinterpreted from its original intent
um
uh but uh yes i would say that the folks
who
tend to support an authoritarian shift
or would support an authoritarian shift
in the united states who are not
supportive of democracy as it currently
exists in the united states
will tend to have a disproportionate
number of these weapons 400 million
currently i think in the civilian
population in the united states is just
breathtaking now
what would happen at
you have all these heavily armed people
around and you have a
the implementation of a
authoritarian regime which would have
elements of a plutocracy probably
because it would
be supported by wealthy certain elements
of wealthy elites in the united states
what's going to happen to all these
folks who are heavily armed who suddenly
find that they actually really are
living within a
a dictatorship
that's an interesting question you might
actually find that there's a great deal
of opposition from folks who might have
otherwise supported or originally
supported the shift in the institutions
at this point where it's complete
speculation we have really no idea where
things could go but it's
again what i was doing in my article was
just opening up these questions because
in canada we at least need to start
considering them and talking about them
what do you think the role has been
from seeing um
what's happening in russia for example
or um in in other countries around the
world where i mean really it's it's
these sort of authoritarians that donald
trump sometimes played coy with and
sometimes even expressed admiration for
what what sort of effect do you think
that has had on the population in the
united states
so this is a really interesting question
and development and somewhat unexpected
i mean i've been watching putin's
build-up of arms since since last year
and i actually felt that it was quite
likely he was going to attack ukraine
but i hadn't expected first of all what
we've seen is a democratic rallying
around the world the rallying of
democratic countries to come together in
in the defense of ukraine
uh and all of the folks like victor
orban and jared bolsonero and uh marie
le pen in france all of the folks who
had cozied up to putin in various ways
heading for the exits because all of a
sudden they've been substantially
de-legitimized i mean
this is a real world lesson and what
happens when you get a dictatorship
dictatorships tend to go to war
democracies don't go to war with each
other it's one of the strongest
empirical laws or generalizations in the
social sciences it's called the
democratic peace hypothesis
if you end up with something like putin
or
an authoritarian regime you're much more
likely to go to war because what happens
with these folks and this is part of
what's happening in russia is as their
legitimacy declines internally because
authoritarian regimes tend not to solve
their problems very well they have
economic crises and things as their
legitimacy and popularity declines
internally they pick fights with their
enemies or with external enemies and
to try to build up the leaders try to
build up their authority and popularity
internally by picking fights externally
so
so we're getting a very vivid lesson
in the kind of world we will be creating
if we give up on democracy and i think
in an extraordinary way this is a silver
lining from this this war i mean it's a
terrible terrible situation but it's
sort of reminded everyone in the world
what's at stake
and i think i think it actually puts
donald trump in an interesting way and
something of a
vulnerable position in the united states
as we come into for instance the
midterms and the in the presidential
election campaign that'll be very
interesting to see uh in terms of what
what impact it has for sure uh we're
going to link to thomas homer dixon's
article that's been the jumping up
jumping off point for our conversation
today the new book is commanding hope
the power we have to renew a world in
peril i so appreciate your time today
thank you so much
thank you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show okay this is a story as much about
mental illness as it is about anything
else and we're not we're not ridiculing
mental illness we're not stigmatizing it
we're really talking about the sad state
of affairs in the united states where
there is so much undiagnosed and
untreated mental illness our friend
walter masterson was at the trump rally
in florence south carolina over the
weekend this is the rally we covered
live saturday and we had clips of
trump's speech from yesterday and we got
a little bit of insight into some of the
wackiest characters who were at the
rally yesterday but that was when they
were being interviewed by like
right-wing interviewers who didn't
really know the right questions to ask
walter actually knows what he's doing so
let's get right into this this is i i
believe
this is a clinically insane hypothesis
that this person has and if they were to
sit down with a psychiatrist i believe
they would be medicated for presenting
what this person presents in this video
take a look at this i got a good idea
what's going on in ukraine when they
went into ukraine and they found these
labs
they believed that made that the
deep state
is possibly going to use a bio weapon on
russian people because they've been just
like that they were collecting our dna
in china they've been collecting their
dna as well okay so
chinese dna collection is analogous to
something that the deep state is going
to do
to then bio-weapon the russian
population
wow i mean
this is someone whose brain is
mayonnaise i i i don't know any other
way to describe it so trump and putin
right now are the only ones successfully
fighting against the deep state i think
as well as chi too
who
oh xi jinping
so xi jinping is
fighting against the he's a good guy oh
oh he's fighting against no surprise by
the way that more of these trumpets just
love these dictatorial authoritarians i
could think about it he's not part of
the ccp secretly
[Applause]
xi jinping do you think he's working
with putin and trump against the deep
state i think he probably is yeah
probably i've heard that i mean xi
jinping is working against the deep
state
yeah i've heard that xi jinping modi
vladimir putin donald trump are all
working against the deep state right
those they love their dictators don't
they and you've got the white hat
alliance which is a lot of countries you
know i looked by the way for the white
hat alliance i i found no no record of
it there's a small hacking group called
the white hat alliance it's very clearly
not what this woman's referring to
france he is part of the good guys the
reason i think that is because he's
fixing to go into taiwan you wait and
see what i tell you when he gets into
taiwan guess what he's gonna find
more labs more bio labs that is all
planned out y'all it's all planted this
is one big sting operation
that's what i believe yeah so xi jinping
putin
and trump are the only ones fighting uh
against the deep state and making sure
that there are no bio weapons that's
right now if oh hold on because if they
do not stop them they will release them
right um if if we were to do a skit with
some
person joking about crazy conspiracy
theories you couldn't do any better than
that their their mind is truly
gone or it was never there or whatever
uh here's another example and again
we're not joking when we say mental
illness but
but
we're also not saying
political extremism
is exclusively mental illness we're not
saying that either this just happens to
be the perfect nexus of both here's
another one when it came out it was
corona right
corona
corona is six letters
when you use gematria okay now
gematria is
hebrew numerology the aleph bet okay the
alphabet the hebrew alphabet the
alphabet
uh it's the idea of assigning you know a
to a one to the letter aleph and okay so
so this is hebrew numerology you say a
is one b is two c is three right and you
put corona lined out at six six so
that's six six six but we found that out
so they're saying the white cr wing
crazies found it out so they changed it
to cover
which is c what is this c right
to c huh ovid look it up
ovid means sheep
19
military code for surrender
see
sheep
surrender
that's no joke wow that
so that's from the good liars these are
very sick people and my concerns are too
we should provide access to mental
health services it it i'm not joking
that is one side of this
the other side of this is you don't
correct these views by sitting down with
people and chatting for a few minutes
okay so from an electoral strategy
there's also a question as to what do
you do what do you do
um
and i don't have the answer but it's
very very sad what's going on
uh we are now getting the expert um uh
testimony
of the um
not smartest son of the former president
donald trump i'm talking about eric
trump eric trump went on fox news's
hannity program to try to defend his dad
and attack joe biden on the topic of
ukraine and now at this point
it sort of seems pointless in the sense
that joe biden has an almost 60 approval
on his handling of ukraine which in a
country as polarized as the united
states
when 60 of the country believes you're
doing a good job
that's pretty overwhelming sadly in this
polarized state of affairs trump never
had 60 approval on anything that he
oversaw while he was president and they
clearly know it they're trying to run
interference for trump but remember
trump withheld military aid to ukraine
hoping it would force zelenski to start
providing dirt on joe biden
thanks to that little strategy being
outed trump ultimately had to release
the military aid to ukraine so anyway um
eric trump talks to sean hannity and
it's all completely crazy it's a
delusional fantasy world understanding
of how trump and foreign policy
coexisted and this is the trumpian sort
of analysis that counts as analysis in
their world in in which they live
listen my father would you know call up
and he would have said vladimir don't
even think about it don't even try us
i'm telling you it's not going to work
out very well for you right so this is
the idea that trump was really really
tough on putin and that putin respected
trump now you can say a lot of things
about putin i don't think he really
cares about the welfare of individual
russians he cares about
you know furthering his plans for a sort
of new ussr and that's his priority
uh putin's ruthless and brutal he
disappears uh dissidents he disappears
slash you know disappears and by that i
mean kills and sometimes unjustly
imprisons
media people who don't agree you could
say all that stuff about putin but putin
is way smarter than trump there's no
doubt about that and there is no way in
hell that putin was intimidated in any
way by donald trump let's go to the next
clip by the way my father had a great
relationship with putin we know all the
while he's sending thousands of javelin
missiles to the ukraine isn't that
really amazing by the way
they still are on the ukraine i mean
biden has no relationship with putin and
he's literally sending blankets to
ukraine it's
you know again sean it's so these are of
course lies uh biden and the us has uh
have sent
significant military aid to ukraine
remember that the aid eric trump is
referring to his dad sending was aid
that trump initially withheld
because he was trying to push zolensky
to announce that they were investigating
joe and hunter biden he ultimately
released the aid but again importantly
a good relationship with putin comes
when putin sees
that you're a joke when putin sees that
you're a patsy and that's exactly what
putin saw in donald trump here's one
last clip of eric trump's incisive and
principled analysis of geopolitics why
well listen putin was in with the kgb he
can read people and he could tell that
donald trump was a very strong person
right right no wrong
and again 90 of that sentence is right
putin was in the kgb
putin can read people and he can tell
that donald trump was a very
weak person i mean remember trump coming
out in helsinki and saying listen i
asked him did you hack us did you hack
the u.s
and he said no and he said it very
strongly and i believe him that's what
putin saw in trump trump as a patsy so
nobody ever said eric was the smart one
but now just
obviously i mean just laughably
unbelievable claims about trump's
handling of geopolitics foreign
relations russia and ukraine
we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
here is a voicemail from the man we know
is the most chaotic caller of all time
billy harrison
and um this caller is a great example of
why the united states isn't a better
country okay let's listen
david pakman billy harrison here uh
calling again
i'm calling on the fact that you just
i'm watching your little live video that
you have with trump because i've watched
the live video already but i kind of go
back and watch yours because
you laugh at it really me and my wife uh
i called a while back and
kind of
asked you to me and your debate lie but
you refused to do it as i've said before
billy you can call in when we take live
calls i mean i'm not what do you debate
live i'm not going to fly to wherever
you live and debate you in person if you
call in any time and confront me about
whatever
but
you're claiming about the bible lab in
ukraine that someone has to prove it
that there's no evidence of it
no
see we talked about this earlier
i'm not claiming anyone has to prove
that there's no evidence of it what i'm
explaining is that no one has brought
forth any evidence that the labs in
ukraine are in any way unique or
pernicious
relative to all the other labs that do
pathogen research all over europe and
all over the world and it certainly is
no justification for the russian
invasion that's the issue somebody
commented and called you out on that
uh about turkey carlson saying that it
that it you know that it was true and
they report on it and
you said that it is stupid for someone
to
basically say you know start saying
stuff like that without no evidence
is anybody else even following this
but you don't have no evidence that an
answer and of course this gets us to the
exact uh russell's teapot principle that
i mentioned earlier people who don't
have any understanding of what we what
the burden of proof mechanism is and my
i'm not going to go point counterpoint
with billy harrison but what i do want
to mention is
if someone so misunderstands what is
even being said how do we even talk to
these people they don't even it's not
that we disagree about our analysis
the guy doesn't even have any idea
what's been said he's wrong about what
tucker said he's wrong about what i said
how there's no shared basis of fact it's
a very sad situation in this country
very very sad we've got a great bonus
show for you today sign up at
joinpacman.com
to get access oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors cheese butter is
the delicious gourmet cheese melt that
blends four indulgent cheeses and
seasoned butter i love this stuff
perfect on bread bagel sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below